to explore deep unsolved problems about
the nature and limits of computation
the institute's core activities revolve
around semester-long research programs
on specific topics in the foundations of
computing and related fields
we've been going since 2012 and recently
we learned that our funding will be
renewed for the second decade so we're
very grateful to the simons foundation
for that
for this semester although we've been
operating online only we have two
very active programs one on probability
geometry and computation in high
dimensions
and one on the theory of reinforcement
learning the institute has a
long-standing tradition of
appointing a science communicator in
residence
with the aims of supporting authors and
journalists in the areas of computer
science and mathematics of helping them
connect with the experts who participate
in our programs
of increasing the visibility of
theoretical computer science and of
helping to
educate our participants about
communicating their work to a broader
audience
so we're delighted to have as our
science communicator in residence this
semester
brian christian brian is the
award-winning author of the most human
human
and algorithms to live by these books
have won many awards and commendations
including from the new york times wall
street journal
the new yorker and the mit technology
review
brian's written articles for the
atlantic the guardian the new yorker
the paris review wired and the wall
street journal
and he has a third book coming out in
early october
and we're very happy to be hearing about
uh the topic of that book today brian's
talk today is entitled the alignment
problem
machine learning and human values
welcome brian
thank you so much peter so i'm going to
talk about the book that i've been
writing for the past
four years which is finally coming out
in three weeks
and it feels really fitting to be giving
the first real talk about the book here
at berkeley
because berkeley has really been my home
in my primary academic community during
that time
so i first want to express my gratitude
to citrus where i've been a visiting
scholar starting in the spring of 2017.
and to chai where i've been an active
participant throughout that time as well
and also to the simons institute
attending some of the seminars and
workshops here was
incredibly generative both for
familiarizing myself with certain
technical
concepts connecting certain
interdisciplinary dots and
meeting folks across the community not
just here at berkeley but beyond
so i want to give a special thanks to
brandi nanaki and camille crittenden
at citrus to stuart russell and mark
nitzberg at chai
and to richard carp and kristen kane
here at simons for
inviting me into the fold and making me
feel so welcome and so at home here
and so i'm very honored to be starting
this semester as the scientific
communicator
in residence here at simon's um it's a
great honor to me so
thank you i want to talk about the
central theme of the book which
is the connection between machine
learning and human values
in some ways it feels quite ironic to be
addressing in large part the theoretical
computer science community
particularly those who work in machine
learning and especially in reinforcement
learning
um because in some sense i see my role
as being something of
an ambassador from that community to the
public at large
and so um it was an interesting
challenge to think about how to make an
address
to that community um the second
challenge
for me uh is that the book is very
deliberately an opportunity
for people who are not myself to speak
um i decided very early on that one of
my priorities was to create space
for people in large part to tell their
own stories
there are probably about um between 100
and 150 people
who speak at one point or other in the
course of the book and
i think that um sort of multi-vocal
quality is really one of its
distinguishing features um for better
worst this morning it's just me so you
won't
quite uh get to appreciate that aspect
of the book
um third and finally a big part of what
the book sets out to do
um is to actually teach people machine
learning i believe very passionately
that there are
many careers that are intersecting with
machine learning at this point whether
it is public policy um the law
medicine and so forth and a lot of
people are having to find themselves
kind of skilling up in machine learning
literacy you know midway through a
career that was ostensibly
um about something else um and so a big
part of my goal uh is pedagogy i want
people to
to walk away knowing the difference
between supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning and
what an objective function is and the
difference between
behavior cloning and inverse
reinforcement learning
etc and uh if ever there was a group of
people who did not
need me to give them a primer on machine
learning it is the simon's institute
research fellows so what i would like to
do
is highlight some of the
interdisciplinary connections and the
places where
machine learning makes contact sometimes
in very surprising ways
with other disciplines because i think
it is very broadly true that
um to the degree that ai machine
learning reinforcement learning are
about discovering fundamental aspects of
what it means to think to have a mind
then the further along that field goes
the more relevant existing fields like
developmental psychology cognitive
science education
management science etc become
and so for for the next 30 or so minutes
perhaps i can um
reverse my normal osmosis and instead of
being a kind of ambassador
for theoretical computer science i can
attempt to be an
ambassador to theoretical computer
science and
highlight this what i see as an
incredibly rich circumference of
connections to other fields
and opportunities for research and for
cross-pollination
so on to the central thrust of the book
itself
um before we explore the the actual
contents together
so there's a story that i assume most
everyone
here knows at least to some degree or
another which is the remarkable progress
that has been made in machine learning
particularly
deep learning since the beginning of the
last decade
there is something very poetic to me
about the fact that it
was neural networks in particular that
are responsible for this incredible
breakthrough because
neural networks were essentially one of
the very first
ideas in computing uh they're they're
older than the von neumann architecture
they're they're older than the the
stored
uh program computer um von neumann's
1945 edvac report which
is the first written description of a
stored program computer contains
um in 101 pages only a single citation
which is mcculloch and pitts 1943
so i started researching the life of
walter pitts
um going through oral histories and the
mcculloch archives uh
at the american philosophical society in
philadelphia
and i was astounded at the life stories
of some of these early pioneers
i remember reading an oral history from
one of their contemporaries jerome
ledvin who just casually mentioned
oh yeah and when pitts started working
with mcculloch he was 17 years old
and homeless well that certainly got my
attention
um and warren mcculloch basically came
like became like his foster parent
um the more i read the more fascinating
and poignant that story
became so i thought okay um i found my
my opening scene so it's walter pitts
h12 deciding to run away from home
and of course we all know the story that
that runs
from there through frank rosenblatt and
marvin minsky and seymour papert
the rebirth in the 1980s and then what i
see as kind of this ultimate final
triumph in 2012 with alex net
um when we first meet alex krazevsky in
the book he is
in his bedroom at his parents house in
toronto and his two
uh gtx 580 gpus have been running
uh non-stop for two weeks and now it's
too hot to sleep um
and that was just 2012 not that long ago
and yet
it feels now that we almost live in a
different world
i think we've become um
in some ways desensitized to how
discontinuous some of these jumps
uh have felt and it's important i think
to remember how much they caught even
experts off guard
um so one one example sort of at random
is uh richard sutton uh who authored of
course the
canonical book about reinforcement
learning um
gave a lecture in 2015 at ut austin
uh where he presented a graph and here's
the slide
of the strength of computer go programs
there was this very striking
linear trend line which uh if you
extrapolated it out
he notes that projecting this trend
suggests
a computer will be world champion by
2025
so within 10 years um
and it happened the very next year um
led by the team at deepmind uh led by
david silver um
and i think this is just just a very
striking illustration of how abrupt some
of those
uh jumps uh have been uh
i got very curious by the way in the
origin of this graph
so i started digging into where uh where
rich got it
and the original version had been made
for rich a few years earlier
by a grad student of his named david
silver
uh so i think that's quite ironic indeed
at the same time all of this is
happening in deep learning
uh and deep reinforcement learning um
there is a
subtler but equally significant movement
that's happening within
society which is the penetration of
machine learning into greater
and greater contact with human and
institutional decision making
so to illustrate this this is a look at
the number of states in the u.s that are
using statistical risk assessment models
to assist in parole decisions
so um by
1935 it's just one u.s state
by 1960 it's 2 out of 50.
by 1980 it's 4 out of 50
then 12 and then in the year 2026
um and by 2003 the association of parole
authorities internationals
handbook for new parole members writes
in this day and age making parole
decisions without the benefit of a
research-based risk assessment
instrument
clearly falls short of accepted best
practice
um and in 2016
um supreme court chief justice john
roberts is visiting
rensselaer and he is asked by rensselaer
president shirley ann jackson
can you foresee a day when artificial
intelligence
will assist with courtroom fact-finding
and even
more controversially perhaps judicial
decision-making
and roberts responds
it's a day that's here
and so i think on both of these counts
both the astonishing
capacity of these systems on the one
hand and
on the other hand the increasing surface
area on which they touch our lives
people began as we all know to get
concerned and these concerns
take root across two distinct but
fundamentally united groups
there are people worried about the
present day
about whether the systems currently
being deployed really represent the
interests of the people that they're
supposed to
and there are people worried about the
near-term future
as we increase and increase the
capability of these systems
that we might be setting ourselves up
for a truly catastrophic failure
again despite their different priorities
and
distinct but overlapping communities i
began to see the fundamental question
underneath
each set of concerns as being the same
so put most simply
how can we make sure that these systems
do what we want
and this problem of course has a name
and the name is
the alignment problem
and i think this is more or less
where the public conversation around
machine learning around
ml ethics and technical ai safety uh
kind
of ends but in my view
this is really where things get
interesting and this is
this is really the point where the book
begins so if we look to the period of
roughly 2014 to 2016 as
a giant pulling of the fire alarm
uh then to continue the analogy what we
begin to see from
roughly 2016 to the present uh is
the first responders start showing up
uh this set of concerns moves from being
marginal and to some degree
taboo to comprising one of the central
concerns
of i think of the field we have this
explosion of
workshops conferences research centers
non-profits grants
all happening within this short time and
i heard from people
you know again and again that they they
would go to
for example nurips in 2016 and tell
people that they worked on
safety and the response would be
something like safety
uh and then by 2017 there was an entire
nurse workshop
workshop on safety um i heard versions
of this story again and again you know
with the years perhaps plus or minus one
and the area of focus being you know
safety fairness transparency etc
um so there is this incredible zeitgeist
i think pivoting towards these issues
there is a first generation of phd
students
just now graduating who um
are have matriculated with the explicit
purpose of wanting to work on ai ethics
and ai safety
um and not only is there this incredibly
spirited energy around these topics but
there are actual results there are
tangible victories uh being notched and
there is this
agenda now uh that is well underway
um so with ironically a
minimum of actual computer science and a
maximum emphasis
on the interdisciplinary dimensions of
this field
what does that agenda actually look like
so the book is divided into three parts
which comprise three chapters each
and so i'd like to just take a very
brief
um glance at each in turn
and highlight what i see as being some
of the the frontier of interdisciplinary
connections that exist
around this core theoretical computer
science
contribution so the first chapter starts
with
one of the most visceral and sadly
iconic
examples of machine learning failing in
an ethically significant way which is
um the famous example of the two black
americans being labeled
by google photos in 2015 as gorillas
um we get to meet jackie alstine who
was one of those people and is himself a
software engineer with an ml
uh background and who knew instantly
that
something had gone wrong uh in the
training data that he
as soon as this experience happened to
him he immediately surmised that there
was just a
paucity of black faces in the training
data
so we knew exactly how this had happened
but the question was
why why had that come to be the case
that this this um
training data was so uh unrepresentative
of the population at large
so that's that's the deeper question um
and i think this is a great example of
where
ethical and long-term technical safety
concerns intersect so
you can frame this as a question of
inclusion and representation
uh you can also frame it as a question
of robustness to distributional shift
how do models behave when they get
outside of their training distribution
um
and there is a lot of really i think
exciting and encouraging work being done
here so you have the work of people like
joy bolemweeny and timmy gabriel um and
many others
uh bringing a focus um
to this question of where do these
training sets actually come from
what do they actually look like um and
i think there's an interdisciplinary
theme here as well
um which is that there's also there's an
almost 200 year story
of the intersection of racial justice
and photography so
as i started researching this area i was
fascinated to learn for example that
uh the single most photographed american
of the 19th century uh more than abraham
lincoln etc
was frederick douglass the pioneering
abolitionist
who felt that photography was a critical
tool for emancipation because
of course before photography you had
engravings
which were done by hand and almost
always exaggerated black people's
features in stereotyped ways
so there's an irony that we go from the
19th century
in which the single most photographed
american is
frederick douglass um to
the 20th century where commercial film
is being
developed and calibrated um by color
accuracy with reference to
a model the first model that kodak used
was named shirley and so these have
become known as
shirley cards which until the 1970s were
almost exclusively white
um and in the in the book we get to meet
some kodak
executives who uh describe amazingly
that they were receiving pressure in the
60s and 70s
from the chocolate and furniture
industries
um to make film that better portrayed uh
brown hues um but
changing the uh nature of the film of
course changed
the um the ability of the film to
represent people with darker skin
um so here we are in the 21st century in
which we have these
um kind of weird echoes back to the 20th
century
um and we have this broad uh
broad movement of of questioning what is
the nature
of these training sets and um you have
people
like neil jan and huhan
publishing statistics about the
composition of labeled faces in the wild
and showing that for example it contains
twice as many images of george w
bush as it does of all black women
combined
um and as recently as i believe the fall
of 2019 a warning
label now appears on the page where you
would go to download the
lfw data set saying basically caution
this data set is
not representative of the us or the
global population
the other domain that we explore in this
chapter is language models and looking
at the many stereotypes that emerge
all the way from simple word embedding
models like word to vec and glove
all the way to the more modern enormous
trend uh transformer networks like gpt
2 gbt3 um these models are often
employed i think
uncautiously in recruiting and hiring
contexts
and we encounter the story of an amazon
team that
looks with horror at the individual
terms that their model is kind of
upranking and downranking
there's a theoretical computer science
story here um in
work on de-biasing vector models by
collapsing the gender space
um and although the story there is is
not quite so simple
um and there's work as recently as two
weeks ago from open ai
on fine-tuning these big transformer
models
from human preferences um and i think
that story is
also very much being worked out um the
interdisciplinary
interdisciplinary story here is that
we've added
a new tool uh to the arsenal of social
science that
um as these language models become in
some ways
uncanny reflections of
uh human norms and human biases
including the ones that we
would rather we didn't have they become
a measure for actually watching society
change and so there's been some really
interesting
interdisciplinary work on applying these
models to historical uh
corpora you know 1930s 40s 50s 60s 70s
and watching in a quantifiable way
uh the norms of the society change and
so i think
um machine learning is not only
a a tool um
that uh it's not just the case that
social scientists um
you know are increasingly having input
in these models but that these models
are also giving social
scientists um a brand new set of subject
matter and
an entirely new lines with which to look
at the world
so the the second chapter is fairness
and i think most people who are familiar
with the machine learning literature
on fairness know about the compass tool
which predicts the risk of recidivism
and is used in pre-trial detention so in
this chapter i really try to dig into
the back story so
um statistical risk assessment models go
back to the 1920s
and the there's a time when the
conservative head of the parole board in
illinois was thinking about getting rid
of the parole system entirely
um and he believes that is simply an an
asset to criminals uh
that you would ever let them out uh
ahead of the full sentence
and a sociologist uh from chicago named
ernest burgess ends up
collecting enough data to persuade him
to change his mind
um and uh
that is really the beginning of the the
use of statistical risk assessments
um in the criminal justice system and
uh looking through archival uh
newspapers was
was very enlightening to me uh for
example most of the criticism against
these models in the 30s
uh was coming from the right whereas
today it
is largely speaking the progressives
that are the most skeptical
um so i think the the most visible
of the contemporary critiques of these
models is from
pro publica julia anguin um who uh
made this very famous article machine
bias critiquing the compass model
um and i got to meet both julia anguin
and the creator of compass tim brennan
um and
i was quite pleased to actually find a
bit of common ground where i
could uh i could convince them to to
agree with
one another um the there's a theoretical
computer science story here on how do we
operationalize
fairness and um this goes through the
work of people like cynthia dwork
mort's heart uh john kleinberg sam
corbett davies alex toldichova
christian lum looking at everything
from these impossibility proofs
of uh mutually satisfying different
metrics of fairness
to things like the long-term feedback
loops that exist when these systems
uh get into put into practice and start
generating the very data
that they will go on to be trained upon
the interdisciplinary story here
includes not only
the long-term history of risk assessment
but also contemporary
political scientists like columbia's
bernard harcourt
who argues that the very premise that
better predictions lead to a
better public safety um is itself
wrong um which i think is a very
interesting argument for for people in
in ml to contend with um and more
broadly we have the
the question of uh not just data
provenance
where are the data coming from uh but
the sort of human computer interaction
and the user experience aspect of how
these risk assessment
instruments actually get put into
practice so as part of my research for
this chapter i spent a day
going to arraignment hearings in san
francisco um
right after san francisco began using
the arnold tool
and it was very illuminating to me to
see the degree to which individual
judges
did or didn't actually comprehend uh
this giant printout that they're being
given
with with the risk assessment
information on it
um so there's also this deeper question
of course of
what exactly is the ultimate purpose of
certain aspects of criminal policy
um if we can identify that someone is a
risk
pre-trial well there might be two
extremely different risks that we have
in mind you know there might be a risk
of violent reoffense
there might also be a risk of failure to
appear for the court date
um and if it may be the case that the
solution to the former problem
uh might be incarceration it might not
the solution to the second problem is
probably something like a text message
um and so i think there uh there's a lot
of work to be done not necessarily in
how the models themselves are developed
but in whether they're essentially used
uh
according to you know the label on the
side of the tin and i think there's
there's a lot of work to be done there
um
and and many people of course argue that
uh fine-tuning exactly what the
objective function is of these systems
or exactly what this or fairness
constraints imposed upon them
um that while that discussion is
fruitful there are also ways we can sort
of cut the guardian not entirely
so we could just decriminalize marijuana
for example and then not have to
worry about how to fairly assign
pretrial detention for people who are
arrested for that
there are some states i believe new york
state and maryland if i'm not mistaken
um that are increasingly moving towards
a model where
if you're arrested for a non-violent
misdemeanor then you simply released
full stop and so then you don't need a
model to predict your
whether or not to detain the person if
you simply never detain the person
um in the domain of transparency so
um the chapter in transparency focuses
on the domain of medicine and we
meet microsoft's rich carwana who in the
1990s was developing
machine learning models for predicting
the severity of pneumonia
and uh his neural network model
wins this kind of bake off against uh
you know logistic regression rule-based
models and and so forth
um but very significantly he
urges the doctors that were partnering
with them on the study
not to deploy the neural network
precisely because
he doesn't know what's in it he doesn't
know what it's learned
and in particular the the rule-based
model had learned this rule that
if someone is asthmatic then
we should predict that they are at lower
risk for pneumonia
which if you think about that for a
second doesn't make any sense at all
it turns out that this is actually a
real correlation in the data
but it's precisely because asthmatics
are given
higher priority care that they on
average do have better outcomes than
regular people but
this is precisely the care of course
that the model would deny to those
patients
um so transparency allows us to of
course catch some of these things before
they actually go
into deployment and affect people and
there's a really rich computer science
here that i think is really exciting
from
caruana himself uh trying to explore a
space of models that are
ideally as expressive or capable as
neural networks but
as interpretable as something like a
rule list and so he's
pioneering ideas like uh generative
additive models and his own sort of
personal extension of that
um to people like cynthia rudin at duke
university who are
exploring the space of certifiably
optimal simple models um so rather than
using our computational horsepower
training a big model
we use our computational horsepower
exploring the space of simple models and
finding the ideal simple model
um and on the
sort of deep learning side we have
people like openai's chris ola
working on unpacking and visualizing
deep convolutional networks
and people like google's bee and kim
working on
concept activation vectors and
interpretability measures using
high level human concepts so the
interdisciplinary story here in my mind
is that
transparency is fundamentally a human
concept
a model is transparent to the degree
that people understand what's going on
and use it appropriately um there is
nothing in the abstract that
transparency means
outside of that and so user studies
should be totally unavoidable um and not
only that
but they are often counter-intuitive so
one of the results here that comes to my
mind
is the work of jen wartman vaughan and
her collaborators um
who showed that simple transparent
models
with a small number of parameters and
clearly visible weights
were much more trusted by human users
even when those models were operating
outside their training distribution and
output and garbage
um so i think user studies like that are
really
useful at um you know
problematizing that the simple story
that we might otherwise get
about thinking about model transparency
um
so there's also the legal angle
obviously so transparency intersects
with the law and things like the gdpr um
and i also think there's a critically
interesting intersection here um
with a bunch of mid-20th century
psychology so there's
there's a tradition within psychology
going from ted sarban in the 1940s to
paul meal in the 1950s to robin dawes in
the 1970s
looking at comparing expert human
judgments to linear models with uniform
weights
unit weighted regression and the tldr is
that unit weighted regression
demolishes expert judgment
even when you still give the human
expert the results of a unit weighted
regression
uh they're still worse than just using
the regression on their own and when you
give the machine learning model the
human judges uh
decisions as input the model doesn't
even use it uh it's just not helpful
um and i think this is really really
provocative and
and in particular um one of the things
that robin dawes was interested in
is this question of how do you build a
model when you don't
have an objective function so you want
to identify high schoolers that will go
on to flourish by getting higher
education
okay well first of all you're going to
have to wait 20 years to get
the training data for that and you have
to implement your model
now secondly what do you mean
flourish uh what how do you
operationalize this idea of someone who
uh you know responds well to to going to
college
um it might take a really long time to
figure out how to operationalize that if
you if you can
um but you have to make the model now so
what do you do
um and amazingly there are still results
that you can prove about what a good
model might look like even under those
conditions
um and i think results like that are are
relevant for
thinking about sort of these farther
future questions about ai
um and what what are the objective
functions that we really want to give
them
um and again this is happening in
psychology in the 1970s
but it feels in some ways more relevant
now than ever
so that's part one which looks at
supervised and unsupervised learning and
present day risks um part two turns the
focus to reinforcement learning
specifically
um so in chapter four uh we get to meet
andy bartow and rich sutton and we
learned the the
uh roots of reinforcement learning in
the ideas of harry klopf
who had this idea that neurons were what
he called heterostatic maximizers
pushing back on the cybernetics movement
of the 40s and 50s that thought that
purposeful behavior necessarily required
negative feedback in
a system that wanted to reach
equilibrium and stay at rest
um harry klopp said no that's that is
not what life is like that is not what
organisms are like we are maximizers um
and there's a deeper historical story
here too though which goes all the way
back
to the 1890s and the work of edward
thorndike on what he called the law of
effect
um which is that you know by default we
take actions randomly
the results of those actions are in his
words either satisfying or annoying
um and that we we modify accordingly to
do more of the satisfying things and
less of the annoying things
um and there's this wonderful historical
moment here where
it turns out that edward thorndike and
gertrude stein were classmates at
harvard
in william james's psychology class in
1896
um and uh gertrude stein described him
as a
as a funny a funny character
um and these ideas really um
carry all the way through to
reinforcement learning in the 20th
century
and so in this con in this chapter we
talk about rl concepts like
credit assignment the difference between
value learning and policy learning
temporal differences um knowing my
audience i think it's fair to imagine
that you don't need me to say too much
more about that
um but there are a number of really rich
connections here um
rl is premised on this idea that rewards
are scalar
uh they're cardinal they're fungible
anything can be compared to anything
real life doesn't always feel that way
right so we we agonize do i do
the thing that's the most lucrative do i
do the thing that's the most prestigious
or do i do the thing that's the most fun
um well
rl traditionally doesn't have this
problem right the rewards are scalars so
you just compare four to five to six
and you do the six um so there are
philosophers like oxford's ruth chang
who think that this um fundamentally
multi-dimensional character of human
rewards
uh what she calls incommensurability uh
this inability to be collapsed from a
vector
representation to a scalar um is
absolutely central to the human
experience
um people from the rl community
essentially counter-argue that you
you do in the end decide and so you can
kind of infer that there was a scalar
attached to that that was greater than
the scalar of something else and
um of course this uh really intersects
with economics and
revealed preferences and utility and
needless to say there's an entire
literature there
uh from pareto to von neumann et cetera
you also have contemporary people in the
neuroscience community people like
paul glimcher and his colleagues at nyu
trying to unpack the actual mechanisms
by which the mind attempts to do this
dimension reduction
uh in the space of value um and
looking into the question of where and
how and with what you know model
is the brain doing that um there's a lot
that we are starting to know
uh in the last 20 years but a lot that
still out there to be learned
um i think the the most thrilling
collision between
um rl and neuroscience is the dopamine
system
so some of you may know this story and
i'm compressing a lot here
but in
the 1990s it was shown by peter diane
terry sinowski read montague that
temporal difference learning basically
explained this open problem
in understanding the function of the
dopamine system and i for me that's just
this totally climactic moment
of uh the science coming full circle
that these models that had grown out of
animal learning in the late 19th early
20th century
finally come into their own and not only
that
but actually solve this outstanding
riddle in the way that the human brain
works i think that's
um a really really encouraging indicator
that rl is basically on the right track
and that we're discovering
um fundamental mechanisms of learning
not not just
engineering practices that work for
specific problems but universal
mechanisms for learning that
evolution has stumbled into again and
again
so from there we get into shaping and
um you know anyone who works in
reinforcement learning is familiar with
the delicacy of designing appropriate
incentives
um and there's a fascinating
interdisciplinary story here too that
starts um with bf skinner during world
war ii
teaching pigeons um because he's been
assigned this project
to put pigeons inside of bombs and have
them
peck at images of bomb targets uh to
create like live homing missiles
basically
um and he has this quote that uh you
know my my colleagues and i knew that in
in the eyes of the world we were totally
insane um
and along the way he does he develops
these principles of what he calls
shaping
that you can start approximating uh
rewarding approximations to the behavior
that
you want and so this idea obviously goes
through theoretical
rl um and you have
uh the work of stuart russell and andrew
ung
in the late 90s showing that you know
the way to avoid
um problems of incentive
is to uh create what's called a
conservative field or basically make a
situation where
if you return to where you started that
the net
shaping uh reward is zero um uh put
differently we wanna
reinforce states of the world not uh
actions of the agent
um and this ends up having
uh all these ramifications in the
cognitive science community
um so for example the work of my good
friend and collaborator tom griffiths at
princeton
um his former phd student from berkeley
faulk leader using these principles
of uh directly borrowing ideas from the
shaping theory
um to create mechanisms for what they
call
optimal gamification so how do you
incentivize people
um not only in a way that doesn't lead
to
uh you know degenerate behavior but but
in ideally the the optimal way
and so the computer science uh or the
the cognitive science rather is
borrowing that idea very directly from
the rl
theory and i think there's a lot more to
be worked out there as well
um of course we know that
you know not not only are we
motivated by explicit incentives from
outside but
anyone who spent time with kids and
animals knows that
um we're motivated intrinsically as much
as extrinsically
um uh and it became obvious in the mid
20th century that you know rats
were willing to walk across an
electrified fence just to peek around
the corner
uh monkeys are as willing to lever press
for uh
to look out a window as they are for
food um and so this
started an effort within psychology to
try to understand the nature of
intrinsic as opposed to extrinsic
motivation
and there's a long and wonderful history
here
the computer science story i think is
people like google brains mark bellamar
who's working on uh extending
count-based exploration
into non-tabular settings um
people like jurgen schmidhumer who's
thinking about intrinsic motivation as
the ability to compress uh information
people at open ai
like yuri berda and harry edwards um
and here at berkeley uh people like
deepak pathik
pulkit agrawal um trevor daryl
exploring intrinsic motivation uh based
on on the idea
that the agent be motivated to take
actions essentially which surprise it
um so as this formal uh work in rl is
getting worked out there's this
all of these connections to infant
psychology um there was a great story
that
alison gotnik berkeley psychologist told
me
about reading about uh trevor
and some of his students work in the
berkeley newsletter and they were
talking about how interested they were
in taking her
ideas about infant uh curiosity and
applying them to rl
and she emailed them like guys i'm i'm
right here i'm like
across the street uh let's actually
collaborate on this and so it's been
really exciting to see
um those two worlds come together um
and on the one hand developmental uh
psychologists are using
rl as a formal model to explain infant
behavior and at the same time
uh the people in rl are turning to uh
what we know about infants to think
about
uh motivation and intrinsic drive uh
that might be useful
uh just in in exploration uh for rl
so the third part of the book um
gets most squarely into the question of
normativity and aligning deep rl agents
with human norms and human values so
one of the things one of the central
themes that anyone knows
um in rls what's called imitation
learning or sometimes behavior cloning
um and there's a really really rich
story here
um not only the computer science story
um in the book we
we meet dean palmerlow from cmu who um
is crazy enough to drive all the way
from pittsburgh to lake erie on the
highway for two hours
um letting a neural network steer his
car in 1990
um using a system that had one tenth of
the processing power
of a first generation apple watch um
so the the surprisingly long uh and
slightly daredevil
history of behavior cloning uh in
self-driving cars that continues all
all the way to this day and we meet
waymo engineer
stefan ross who developed the dagger
algorithm for avoiding cascading errors
um
in imitation learning there's also this
wonderful human story here too
which is that um zoologically all of our
words for imitation not just in english
but in
almost every language uh we say you know
to ape something
uh but the real prolific imitator in
nature
is not apes at all and there's an entire
uh
primatology literature on just on that
topic
um but it is in fact uh humans um
and furthermore the human capacity for
imitation is extremely
sophisticated um and goes way beyond
merely duplicating uh behavior in in
ways that are
surprising um and and really i think
informative uh for thinking about how
this might work um
with machines um so
uh there's also i think a really
interesting connection
in imitation um to
uh not just primatology but
philosophical ethics um
and in the interest of time i won't get
too deeply into it but there's a there's
a classic
philosophical tension going back to the
1970s between what are called
possibilism and actualism so
do you do the very best thing possible
in a situation even if it requires
a very precise follow-through and you
know that you'll screw it up
um or do you do um the the lesser action
that you know you can actually follow
through
so this debate has now been going on for
uh something like
40 years and it's absolutely relevant to
thinking about
things like batch off policy rl um so
i'm really intrigued in the way that
those
literatures are starting to come into
contact
um in chapter eight we get into
arguably the heart of contemporary ai
safety research so ideas around
inverse reinforcement learning
cooperative inverse reinforcement
learning
deep rl from human preferences and so
forth um
and irl itself has this wonderfully
colorful history that it really goes
back to
uh stuart russell walking to safeway um
and thinking about his gait as he went
down the hill
um and this gets him thinking about you
know what
what is it that animal and human gates
optimize
why is it the case that it we still need
to hire motion capture people and we
can't reliably produce like realistic
looking gates
um and uh this gets into the idea of irl
so if the human gate is the answer
what's the question um there's an entire
interdisciplinary literature here
just on the science of gait and all the
different theories that people have had
over many decades for
why horse gates are certain ways and why
there are phase
transitions in quadruped gates at
certain speeds and
are they optimizing stress on the joints
are they optimizing you know
calorie load etc and
irl now it directly offers us a way to
answer and address questions like that
um so there's this purely
theoretical story that goes through um
you know peter abel's work on getting
helicopters to do
stunts uh people like chelsea finn
working on things like
guided cost learning um to uh
jan laika and paul cristiano very
memorably teaching
a uh a mujoko agent to do a backflip
just
by comparing different clips
and picking the one that looks slightly
more like a backflip um
there there are i think many
interdisciplinary questions
here um there are ethical questions
about recommendation systems you know
you can you can infer
what someone wants but um are they
acting the way that they want to be
acting in the first place i think that's
a that's an interesting question
um more broadly as robots become more
capable
and able to work sort of our elbow to
elbow with humans
in manufacturing settings and so forth
um
there's an entire interdisciplinary
literature on human
teamwork um and so i'm thinking about
people like
mit roboticist julie shaw who has done
a lot of work borrowing ideas straight
out of the human human teaming
literature
and showing that they apply um basically
wholesale
uh into thinking about human robot uh
collaboration uh in in factory settings
and so i think there's so many cases
like this
where there is just this windfall of
insights
ready ready to be plucked basically um
and as these systems get more and more
capable i think that's only going to
continue to be the case so the book ends
with a chapter about uncertainty
um so we meet stanislav petrov the
soviet officer who uh single-handedly
saved 100 million people's lives
by not doing anything when his missile
system told him that the u.s was
attacking
but the attack seemed weird to him
so he simply didn't do anything um and
uh
you know to some degree to save the
world by that um so this theme of
uncertainty and in particular what
action to take
in the face of uncertainty i think is
very interesting uh in an ml context
so you have people like oregon's tom
dietrich
who talks about what he calls the open
category problem you know it's one thing
to classify uh classify images as a set
of
one of a set of categories but most of
the things in the world are actually in
none of those categories
so how do how do you deal with that um
there are people like oxford yaringall
who are working on the uncertainty
estimates you get out of bayesian neural
networks and how you can approximate
that using dropout
um there are people here at berkeley and
chai
um smith and millie dylan hadfield
mannell peter
uh abeel anka dragon stuart russell
working on the idea that if you're
interested in obedience in a system
the ability to intervene and stop it
the system must necessarily be uncertain
have some uncertainty over what it
thinks your objectives are
again here at berkeley gregory khan and
his colleagues at bear have worked on
robots that slow down
when they um their collision predictor
model becomes uncertain
um using a mixture of dropout and other
techniques
and i think there are there are a number
of questions here um
in purely in the theoretical computer
science side
around how do you measure uncertainty
how do you measure
the impact that your action might have
um and then what do you do in the face
of that uncertainty and with that sense
of
impact so on the impact side there are
people like future of humanity institute
stuart armstrong
deep minds victoria krakovana oregon's
alex turner
uh working on operationalizing uh this
notion of high impact actions in an rl
setting
um and uh there's also an entire medical
ethics literature
on what do you do in the face of
uncertainty there's also a legal
literature on this idea of preliminary
injunctions or irreparable harm
and i think all of these things start to
become relevant and start to feed into
what we
are doing in the field of rl so
to conclude i think as we
gather here at the end of 2020 um
in sum i think we're ready to to etch
another chapter into this history so
we have seen first the promise and
secondly the peril
uh of these systems and we're now at the
beginning of what i see as the the third
phase
um there's a small but brilliant group
of people
beginning to rally and muster around
these images
these issues the first responders as i
say are on the scene
and i hope we can grow these numbers and
i hope that um
the book inspires people into this area
which i see as
being not only one of the most
fascinating and dynamic
um areas but also one of the most
important projects um
in computer science and and frankly in
all of science um
and i think this is a challenge for me
this is an opportunity to meet that
challenge head on
and also a chance to learn i think
something really
radical and profound about ourselves so
as a place to end i i was going through
some archival papers of alan turing's
and i came across a conversation that he
had on bbc radio in 1952
and um you know we'll skip some of the
context but he's saying you know i was
doing a lot of work trying to teach this
machine to do something very simple
and a very great deal of instruction was
needed before i could get into
any results um the machine learned so
slowly that it needed a great deal of
teaching
and one of his uh fellow panelists
interrupts him and says
but who is learning you or the machine
and he says well i suppose we both were
so with that i just want to say thank
you and i welcome any questions that you
might have so thank you very much
thanks very much brian that was uh
really great
um you uh are welcome to use the q a
feature if you'd like to um
uh ask ask any questions um well
while folks are thinking about it um uh
so it struck me in looking at the the
table of contents of your book that you
went through it was a very uh
logical progression you know with the
titles that you had it could have been a
textbook but
um it's really clear that the book's
filled with um
you know fascinating stories um so i'm
curious about so
for instance i was surprised to learn
about um walter pitts being a a homeless
prodigy um yes but
so i i guess um i'm interested in how
the
the stories have shaped how you chose to
present the topics in the
in the book yeah i think that you know
one of the
challenges in writing non-fiction is
that you have to juggle these different
things
right so to your point it is to some
degree a kind of a textbook it's sort of
a
sheep and uh wolf in sheep's clothing
it's you know
a textbook um that is uh presented as a
as a narrative um so that it can reach a
broader audience and
so for me i had to really juggle the
question of what i saw
as being kind of the central result in
an area
with what seemed like the best story
um and sometimes those things lined up
really naturally
um so for example you know rich caruana
discovering that
pneumonia uh his the pneumonia model
predicts that if you have asthma
that you should go home and you know
it'll be fine um
that is both a wonderful story on its
own
and it also happens that rich is today
you know one of the people who's really
active in this area so
that that kind of presented itself to me
on a platter
um other cases where um you know in the
uncertainty chapter
it opens with this somewhat canonical
story of the soviet uh
officer um and
uh that's not it's not on its face a
machine learning story uh
story although he was using a machine
learning system that was
giving him this uh assessment that okay
it looks like there's the u.s attack
we're raiding it high confidence um
uh and he knows that what he's supposed
to do is pick up the phone and
tell his superiors but he knows that
they're going to order this missile
launch
and so he's effectively it's effectively
his hand on the button and he
decides not to do anything um and so
there was just a
an anecdote that i found of a machine
learning researcher
um talking about
in the past when if someone had given
them a thought experiment where there
was a button they could press that would
convert the universe to hedonium
you know computationally optimized
matter for producing unpleasant
experiences
they would have pressed that button and
now they're not so
sure uh you know and when people mention
that thought experiment they say i don't
know maybe
maybe we shouldn't press that button and
so that for me was both
um a literary moment where i could
connect this historical example to a
present-day contemporary
researcher but also a chance to have
some literary symmetry where the chapter
begins with someone not pushing a button
and it ends with someone not pushing a
button so um
each chapter offered me different
opportunities for that but it was
very much um an exercise to try to
balance the the curriculum if you will
and the just the the pure storytelling
yeah fantastic um we
we have a few questions but we're
running short on time maybe
maybe just the first one up there anna
asks are there any particular areas that
you think should be receiving more
attention
than they are now or any communities
that you think that you think should be
talking to each other more
oh it's it's hard to say in a way
because i feel like the entire book is
that you know
it's like all of these people should be
talking and for me
one of the one of the pleasures of the
book um
is that i actually um you know i got to
be more than a fly on the wall i
actually got to
um have conversations with people where
i said oh
you know so-and-so is working on exactly
that and you know here's someone in
cambridge who's working on that
um and people's ears would perk up and i
get to write letters of introduction and
so
um you know for me that's one of the
great pleasures of getting to do
a sort of inter broad interdisciplinary
work like this
is to to actually get to stimulate some
of those connections
um it's it's really hard to pick just
one but i mean i think
that a lot of the work on infant
cognition is is pretty amazing and that
comes up again and again it comes up in
shaping because infants are really good
at thwarting i mean and small children
not just infants
really good at thwarting the incentives
that you try to design as a parent
in ways that are i think indicative of
problems that we can expect from
you know rl systems more generally
all the way through intrinsic motivation
to imitation to
the ability of children as young as
18 months old to infer from your actions
what you're trying to do even if you're
failing to do it
which is this sort of irl thing so i
think that
the connections between the infant mind
and and
ai obviously go all the way back to the
very beginning turing was talking about
you know a man
imagine building a program that
simulates the child's mind not not the
adult's mind then all we have to do is
subject it to the appropriate course of
education so that's a very old idea
um but in some ways it feels like it's
just bearing fruit now
and and it has far is far from being
exhausted so i think that's that's
really a really rich area that has a lot
to offer
all right well i think we're going to
have to cut it off there there is
several more questions but uh we're out
of time
thanks again ryan that was a really uh
fascinating talk
it is my pleasure absolutely thank you